[Music]
you are being honored tonight as well as
I believe next was a Thursday on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame when it rains it
pours exactly I don't know how this
happened
surprise me to learn that you did not
already have a star on the water aren't
you kind to say that because you know I
swing wildly between saying gosh darn I
deserve it too I'm not worth I mean
seriously if you compare it to like
James Cagney or some of the all-time
greats
of course they don't deserve it but then
again as I said there's somebody on
there that got got a star for just one
crappy reality show I won't mark hamill
you are more than worthy of that well
thank you for saying that that's very
kind you and James Gunn got a little
into it on Twitter about possibly doing
something isn't it crazy sitting there
you know as I do I mean I used to do
crossword puzzles or the jumble and now
I'll have Twitter on and some persons a
said hey James why don't you put Mark
Hamill in the next guardians of galaxy
and to my surprise James Danson will he
lives right around the corner maybe
though we'll have coffee we'll talk so I
answered I said I would be happy to do
so not only as a good neighbor but as an
unemployed actor now I don't know if
anything will come of it but I'm just
thinking it's so funny how these things
happen the next day James and I got into
it on Twitter whether or not you would
save a poured or baby groups
well Groot apparently can regrow himself
you know I'm really a disturbed by how
many people are looking at pores is
potential menu items roast pork and
fricasseed all this stuff is it really a
pork should be a pet you're not on the
menu
Loki's fish right he doesn't eat pork so
I don't know it's very disturbing but
people can't resist the upon of porkchop
I think that's what started about just
driving me congratulations
thank you
[Music]